[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum uh yeah i just i had a
weekend man did you know i was just in
uh metropolis illinois and i i had a con
and there's a lot of people there and uh
it was busy and it's metropolis it's
like it's the home of superman it was a
superman celebration that they do every
year welling went with me we did big
smallville nights it was uh
it was delightful the people were
delightful and uh
i stayed at a casino a place called
haras
where you
sleep and also you can gamble downstairs
and did you i did how'd you do not well
oh
see gambling uh vegas wasn't built on
winners ryan
no it was not no it was not it was built
on idiots like me and me yes not a good
gambler no me neither
never have been but it's a it's a good
trait it's better to be bad at something
and learn and say you know this isn't
for me then hey i got some luck and
because you just never come out on the
good side
that can be rough it can be rough great
guest today
very excited just going to get to it
here in a second uh
uh we'd love you if you enjoy this
podcast today if you're a big nathan
phillian fan the day why not maybe just
give us a shot and listen to us every
week
um subscribe where can you subscribe
ryan uh at inside of your pod on twitter
inside to be podcast on instagram
facebook
there you go and that
is that and that is that i don't i'm not
gonna beg for people to listen i feel
like the the the show speaks for itself
i think it's a good show i think we get
good guests
i think uh they're candid and open
conversations we talk about mental
health and i hope people will stick
around and not just come around for uh
the guests that they're here for yeah
that's all i'll say about that yeah
uh you could also join patreon if you'd
like and that supports the podcast in
many ways there are different tiers
where one where i send you packages and
a little letter and all the stuff and
merch and
you can go to patreon patreon.com
patreon.com inside of you that's right
that's that's correct that's right also
you can go to the merch store i've got
new inside you zip ups and then drinking
glasses and autograph stuff at the
inside of you online store and if you
can go to if you want to go to uh
support the band go to sunspin.com and
you can get a zoom with us
uh you can zoom with me all that stuff
i'm on the cameo also
the new podcast is coming out yes big
news the biggest news ever you're
hearing it right now
tom welling and i
and also ryan here is a big part of it
ryan i'm also part of this is part of
this
it's called it's a new podcast
it's called
talkville
it is a rewatch podcast
tom and i will watch an episode ryan
will watch an episode and then on the on
the podcast we will talk about the
episode what we liked what we didn't
like what ryan liked
we will talk uh freely and openly about
each episode in order from the pilot
onward we hope you join this join us
it's going to be a great time it already
is we've filmed a few there's a hotline
where you could ask questions where you
have a patreon that you can join um
it's it's just really exciting this is
big this is huge uh let's let's hope so
this is what people wanted do you think
when when they heard that you were
stepping behind the mic
i think this is what uh a lot of people
been itching for for a long time
i hope they watch i hope they watch or
they hope they listen july 13th is the
big release date every wednesday
thereafter you'll hear and see um
talkville
a smallville rewatch podcast
more news to come but just put that on
your calendar and tell everybody and
then mother
enough about me let's get into the guest
now uh by the way did you have a good
time where were you i
was in england france spain and then
england again
just brilliant huh
yeah exhausted
it felt simultaneously like a month and
also like a day
you know what i mean yeah it goes by
fast but yet it's the days are long it's
just because we only spent three nights
in a place and uh but no i
my
my second cousin once removed got
married good for him her her
and uh
it was a great wedding
that was nice
yeah it's weird to be back well i know
it's weird for me too and we haven't
like done the show for a while you and i
haven't done an episode in
weeks yeah weeks and in fact we're not
gonna i'm going to australia now to do
some con a con convention supernova so
i'll be gone for two weeks perth and
sydney we're stockpiling some content
yes so uh when we get back
we're going to hit the ground running
so we'll get some we'll get some
episodes in the can and do all that but
we have a great guest and this guest
today
uh has been a guest before
uh i love this guy love having him on he
uh
handles himself really well he's always
got a lot to talk about speaks his mind
there's a couple things that i asked him
about and he didn't
have to think about them and sort of
like gage like how will i answer michael
he answered it how he wanted to answer
it and i and i like that he's very
forthcoming he's a talented talented man
he's also very handsome it was good to
sit across from him in the present
yeah
he's all right he's not he's fine he's
fine whatever uh whatever everybody
loves this guy so without further ado
let's get inside of nathan fillion
it's
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
dude yes you are like first of all are
you going to james gunn's wedding yes so
am i yeah
aspen i've never been well here's the
thing i get altitude sickness
so i'm going
but i'm going to have to take some stuff
beforehand so what has to happen in
order for you to get sick you're just
elevation if i drink
if i drink
without drinking water beforehand
i need to hydrate myself if you're just
in the mountains is this i just remember
i went up in a gondola in aspen once and
i was on a it was like a celebrity thing
and i remember cuba gooding jr looked at
me goes oh damn rosenbaum you're green
as [ __ ]
because that's how he sounds cause you
know i've been friends with him for a
while but so nausea is what you think uh
just complete exhaustion and a little
nausea just like absolutely no strength
like it just i turned like you just feel
really sick almost like have you had
covet yeah i got the original
brutal i did too
it was brutal that was nuts what how
long did you have it three weeks
three weeks of hell yeah did you lose
sense of smell and taste uh no but i
couldn't eat anything i couldn't hold
anything down it was like a
four days of chills like really really
hard chills and my back hurt
jesus and i couldn't focus worth the
damn i couldn't keep anything down and
then just three weeks of like the flu
was it work were you working then it was
christmas vacation so that's how it's
built my christmas are you serious
with cobin what a drag have you ever had
altitude sickness or have you ever never
experienced that before no because you
travel a lot don't you you do a lot of
crazy things i see deep sea dive in i
knocked out once nitrogen like narcosis
what knarked out knocked out like you
you consume too much nitrous yes too
much nitrogen nitrogen nitrogen yeah
it's in the air we breathe all the time
but when you're scuba diving you breathe
at concentrated levels and if you get
this which was weird because i got it
after the dive like the following day i
was reading a magazine and i got it what
happens
uh i felt like i was a mile away first
of all you feel great it feels amazing
all these weird things happen you feel
drunk you feel high but it's super
pleasant so you don't panic
but it's not good because you'll make
terrible decisions if you get it while
you're scuba diving so how long did you
have this
i was probably about 10 seconds maybe if
only 10 seconds of just pure euphoria if
that yeah and i felt like i was miles
away from the magazine i was reading on
the coffee table did you freak out like
i'm having a heart attack
you feel great
that's part of the thing is it feels
amazing
wow yeah by the way what would we get
james gunn for his birthday because
you're always gift guy but isn't going
there enough i always say if you're
invited to a wedding and you go to the
wedding isn't that enough i think he'll
probably be if he's not registered there
will be something that says if you care
to do something make a charitable
donation that's a guy who's got
everything he's got everything he
possibly wants but aren't you a guy that
always does something unique
yeah but when appropriate yeah if
someone says no gifts you don't you
don't bring a gift
did he say no gifts or we don't know yet
we don't know yet but we don't know i'm
gonna be uh well maybe if there is a
gift if there isn't a registry which i'm
sure there is but if not
you know i'll let you decide and i'll
give you half of whatever it costs
although you might go if it's up to me
right we're going to get him
a c bob
a c bob yeah what's the c box see bob it
kind of looks like a jet ski you know
there's ones with the folding handle
that kind of comes up and could stand on
it that's it that's like ten thousand
dollars not a sea doo but it looks like
that but you hang on to it smaller you
hang on to it and you go into water it's
like a motor that pulls you
oh yeah those aren't that pricey let's
get em we're gonna get one of those do
you think you use it i nope nope but we
would if we ever came to this house and
yeah
if you had an ocean because i have used
those so i know what you're talking
about those are pretty dope there you go
i was in florida using one and you just
it just pulls you around there you go
just you have one don't you i have like
a miniature version for the pool yes of
course come on you're a gadget guy
you're nothing yes yes i mean i went
outside and what did you pull up and
tell the audience what you pulled up
them my little arkamoto
it's called an arkamoto it's called an
arkamoto what is an arkamoto it's an
electric three-wheeled open-air
vehicle
with roll cage and crossover seat belts
you don't have to wear a helmet
it's got a windshield and a roof
but no doors
besides that had a windshield oh yeah it
did have a windshield yeah you had a
windshield with no sides two wheels in
front one wheel and back is it hard to
drive
you know it does take a little bit of
strength to to move the wheel there's a
bit of a power assist if you didn't have
it it'd be it would be awful i wouldn't
put my mom behind the wheel or someone
with a shoulder injury i'd put my mom on
there i'll play that right
but yeah it's uh it's
electric it's quiet it's loads of fun
you put your phone into the bluetooth
speakers you enjoy some tunes while
you're just driving open air it's
fantastic how do you just have one of
those just have one yeah how many uh
cars do you have
i i
because i know you're a gadget guy and
you like toys and you like things and
what happens is when you're in this
industry and you do well what you have
and you've worked very hard and you've
gotten to where you are sometimes
instead of going out and spending money
on you know people buy tons of houses
and this and that right but you like
gadgets and toys and cool things like
that so i uh was leasing a vehicle i
wanted to go electric the electric car i
wanted wasn't available yet so i just
said give me that little electric car
and i bought a little electric bmw
really a little one fully electric yeah
fully electric looks like a little
moon buggy
it's so much fun to drive it's and how
many miles do you get
on a charge yeah probably about 70
70 miles on a charge that's not a lot
it's not a lot it has a little generator
if you if you have range anxiety it has
a little generator that'll kick in it's
got like two gallons of gas and if
you're out there and you're not within a
charge it'll get you another 50 miles
yeah i just bought an electric truck
yeah did you see it out there no in the
driveway that's the electric i
oh we're going to go we're going to
climb all over that thing you can show
me i love it i i i sold my truck
i i just wanted fully electric it looked
really cool i waited three years for it
now this company like really they had to
push things because covet so it was a
year and it was a year and a half and
two years and i was getting frustrated i
bet and finally i got the ribbian
and it is everything i could have wanted
it is a beautiful congratulations thank
you i'm very excited i've never been
excited i i keep cars for a long time i
have a van for seven times i know you're
very very well i have a truck for 10
years i'm not a guy who goes and
splurges and buys expensive [ __ ] right
look at look at my house it's like movie
posters and just you know i i live
pretty modestly i think for the most
part well you have a wonderful home that
you thank you for success on uh
smallville yes marvel and other stuff
but yeah mostly smallville i would say
that probably that was where i was
making the big bugs that's i mean you've
you've built a beautiful spot bruce i
was just commenting on your house when i
came in yeah you like the house i like
that you look like presentation your
house is it's always presentable thank
you it feels lived in too doesn't it yes
it's homey yet it's ever the displays it
just it boggles the mind and it really
shows you where your passions are wow
that's really nice but you know what i
always feel like and i've felt like this
my whole life
i was always counting
my money like in terms of if i worked at
mcdonald's which i did i'd say okay i
have a hundred and sixty dollars in the
bank i could live for a week uh i okay
now i'm in new york and i'm working at
you know i uh
uh telecommunications or something you
know telemarketing i was a telemarketer
okay you have enough to live for two
weeks
okay now you're on small though you
could live for
some years
you know and i always that's how i've
lived because i always think tomorrow's
going to come and i don't want to do you
sit and kind of budget and say well this
is what my expenditures are and this is
how i'm going at this no no i don't get
crazy like that but i i sort of i just
want to like i always think you ball
what if you don't want to you know
because i have questions like you know
what do you really want to do i mean do
you want to you know i like podcasting i
like writing i like certain things that
don't give you
the luxury of being super comfortable
but you know um
i don't know i always have you have you
been one to worry about tomorrow do you
always
plan ahead was there a time when you
worried more and now because obviously
you've been on some big successful tv
series uh yeah well i i try not to worry
too much about it but i do try to plan
for it i this you know it's a fantastic
career we've been
blessed with we can't can't last forever
right uh at one point this town's going
to be done with
nathan fillion and uh i'll it's an
expensive city it's an expensive i think
i'll i'll move on to other places my
plan my big retirement plan did i tell
you this already no no
my my whole dream and retirement plan is
to
you know you ready for this ryan you
ready for this is
i just thought it would look on your
face like that
ryan's interested in this we haven't
talked about this before
i think we did right did we i don't
remember okay i should go ahead and the
concept is buy these little tiny prefab
houses get a property somewhere
put down three two or three these little
prefab
oh you want to come over and visit me on
this island in greece where i brought i
bought some land please come visit
that's your house right there you stay
over there in that house i'll stay over
here in this house we'll party over here
in the barbecue area good night you're
over there i'm over here
inside of you is brought to you by
freedom grooming don't go anywhere
if you've been using razors other
than the razor i'm about to tell you
about
it's just simply amazing ryan yeah
i was lex luthor for seven years and i
had to shave my head and i had nicks and
ingrown hairs and cuts and just
it was a horror movie
it really was and um i unfortunately i
didn't have
the freedom grooming flex series
electric shaver which is uniquely
designed to flex and contour to the
curve of your head
for a smoother faster and safer shape
without the risk of knicks cuts
irritation or ingrown hairs while our
grooming products work anywhere on the
body our strongest demographic is with
our bald community and our advertising
speaks to them
we are proudly supporting our hair free
customers and their journey to bald hood
you guys must give these guys a shot
it's uh it's gonna change your world
shaving with these guys
get the smoothest shave of your life
flexible blades contour to the shape of
your head for a baby smooth shave every
time shave 50 more hair in a single
stroke compared to traditional razors
expect shave times of two to three
minutes not 10 to 15. i spent so much
time shaving my head ryan so much time
when i was when i was bald it took me
forever and if i only had this then
never cut yourself shaving again the
flex series safeguard technology means
no nicks no ingrown hairs no problems
and the flex series waterproof design
means you can shave in the shower with
or without shaving cream so you can
shave wet or dry and 10 000 5 star
reviews you just need to listen up this
is going to change your life
change your life stop
deli slicing your scalp with traditional
razors try freedom today or get it as a
gift with your exclusive 20 off by going
to freedomgrooming.com
inside that's
dot
freedomgrooming.com
slash
inside take it from someone who is bald
for quite a long time
freedomgrooming.com
slash inside
inside you is brought to you by magic
spoon the reason they're still a sponsor
of mine is because
they know how much i love them and they
know how much my listeners love them and
uh thank you for supporting magic spoon
because you know as a child we all
wanted cereal we wanted to eat sugary
tasty cereal every day and as we grow up
um you know the doctor tells you that
your cholesterol is really high or you
know this is bad or your your blood
sugar whatever it is it's not good and
uh what happens we stray away from we
shy away from cereals now right we don't
eat them as much we're like oh i guess
i'll have like some yogurt in the
morning or something but you don't have
to now you don't have to because there
is magic spoon and magic spoon let me
just tell you a little bit about this
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving only 140 calories a
serving it's keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free and low carb build
your own box tell us about the nine
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle you can do it with cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry muffins
cinnamon roll and honey nut even more
exciting magic spoon just brought back
their cereal bars they were so popular
they brought them back permanently it's
the perfectly convenient on-the-go
companion for your cereal you need to
take it from me because a lot of people
have asked me friends have asked me to
email me
is this stuff that good try it taste
magic spoon you're gonna see that you
can enjoy cereal and have like a nice
beautiful breakfast every morning go to
magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so guess what ryan
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money
no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring my podcast
and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts
like that's different well it's
completely different
just uh being
depleted depleted of energy overworked
overworked not making enough time for
yourself yep have you guys felt burnt
out i i know i have i constantly feel
burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yep
listen to better help
um
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself i don't know how
many times i say this on the podcast be
good to you be good to yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
um i know that i get so in my head
that i sometimes don't know what to do
next i don't i'm overwhelmed with life
i'm overwhelmed and i just tend to go
back in the bedroom and just fall on my
bed and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ]
if i could say that i don't think better
help it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but um
talking to a therapist talking to
someone someone who's objective someone
who can you know who listen to you who's
a professional it helps it really truly
helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take
take uh all the patrons and all the
people around the world that use better
help yeah take their word for it yeah um
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy i can
tell you that especially living out here
in california you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours and our
listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help betterhelp.com
inside
do you have sort of a dream
to have like i always had this dream of
like a certain amount of friends that we
just buy a block and we live on a block
and we live happily ever after yeah
building little compounds that's my my
dream but having them in different
because i want something in outside of
vancouver i would like something
edmonton's
edmonton's a little chilly i don't know
that's where you're from right it's
where i'm from yeah it's not my favorite
canadian city it's it's freezing it
holds a lot of you know wonderful
memories for me it's a great city big
mall i'm just not fond of the weather is
really right the weather's hard right
but you do you have a certain amount of
friends like you could say right off the
top of your head like i would want to
live next to these guys sure
would one of them be your brother
sure yeah yeah cause you travel with
your brother don't you yeah we just got
back from a nice little uh he came here
to la
first his daughters came out i was
visiting with them one went back then he
arrived in town the other went home he
and i took off to new york and then to
the bahamas what do you do in the
bahamas we scuba dive and we
barbecue
is it just awesome yeah it's great just
being in a nice spot that's really
peaceful and beautiful and doing
something fun like
diving like that's a
that's an adventure it scares me i don't
think i'll ever do it
scarier than it's not it's
jumping in the water in the ocean is
much scarier than jumping underwater in
the ocean
this whole thing of floating on top not
knowing what's inside of what's
underneath
whatever it is so you're more
comfortable under the water that's right
it's starving for human flesh
you don't know what's under there but
you put on your goggles you get down
there is a lot more have you swam with
sharks yes
with sharks next to you not a cage
yes how terrifying is that it's
the first couple times it happens you go
oh my god there's a shark and what about
it then you realize they really don't
have a lot of interest in you then you
wish they could get a little closer you
get a better picture
uh they're they're totally have you ever
had an experienced water with anything
you know on the list of like man-eaters
the the tigers the bulls the hammer
heads the great whites yeah i've never
been in the water in in that kind of a
situation but yeah sharks yeah but
you've been right up to a shark right
right a shark i've i've been close
enough i could have reached out and
touched the shark yet
how do you feel when you're underwater
with a shark is your heart racing
or are you just completely calm at this
point in the beginning you know you get
kind of conditioned and down and when
they get a little closer there's a lot
of excitement yes but also the whole key
to scuba diving is you know breathe easy
be relaxed expend very little energy you
don't be excited about a shark that
senses excitement in the water right
right the the thing that freaks me out
is when they say
every x amount of feet you have to stop
and recalibrate or what the what the
[ __ ] is it equalize when you're yeah
equalize as you go deeper the the water
is pushing on any air cavities like the
ones in your ears right so you pop your
nose a little bit and you equalize that
pressure see i think i would make a
mistake and i would
you know implode you'd start to feel
them that's cool
you go hang on a second and then you
just hold your nose and kind of just get
a little pop like you went on an
airplane did you ever make a mistake
where you start to feel that
that the pressure that
it's it's kind of like if you if you
stay ahead of it it's when you're going
down you start to
you know when you're acting
there are so many things that you know
how to do just intrinsically you never
turn your back on the camera you never
block a light on somebody else there's
things you well i mean there's things
that you've learned in the beginning
where it's like oh my god i have to keep
track of all these different things
right but now you just you just do them
so yeah so as you go down you you know
the pressure is going to come so you
kind of stay ahead of it it's easier to
stay ahead you know i like having nathan
on the podcast because i learn a lot
i do he knows a lot of things he's very
you're well read well versed i i would
say
you you street smarts well you're street
smart but you also like to know things
are you a reader i uh i wish i was a
better i can only read as fast as i can
move my lips so is that true that slows
everything down i prefer fiction i kind
of i like to absorb it i i go slow i i
move slow through books right
yeah you know you talk about all this
stuff like you know
having a place in greece having a place
in vancouver or doing all these things
but i look at you as someone that i
don't think this guy will ever stop
working i mean he's for someone to do a
show like castle for what seven years
eight thank you eight years and then get
on a show like the rookie
for
five four years now we just did four we
got picked up for five okay picked up
for five yeah
the you do in the lead
i can't imagine being the lead on a
series as a 50 year old man which i will
soon be so i look at you as someone like
going well when is he gonna retire when
is he gonna be done
this guy's gonna go on forever i wish it
were up to me
yeah it is up to you i don't know i mean
it's not like i said you know what i'm
gonna do next i'm gonna do a cop drama i
need next i'm gonna do it it doesn't
happen you know it doesn't happen but
what happens when they throw an offer
out there isn't it easy to also say no
yeah sure i mean if you're in a position
to say no you i don't think we often are
i think you're always in a position to
say no if you've done one series you've
probably made enough money to to at
least be comfortable well that's a short
list of people who have done a series
and can are comfortable enough to say no
to a job
before castle i wasn't comfortable
saying no to jobs right before castle i
needed money right you got a little
course got to live so is there is there
a end game is there a certain time or
you're like you know what this is when
i'm going to retire have you ever
thought of that like i don't want to act
anymore or will you be 85 and still
going strong i think it'll be a feeling
i get i think it'll be apparent right
and i think at that point uh i don't
think i'm gonna stop all together i
think someone's gonna call me up and say
hey we need a
guy to play the grandpa for the
such-and-such how would you feel about
coming in and
being the guy who it'll be a cute we're
rebooting something we're rebooting
castle you're going to be the the
grandpa you're like five episodes would
you do like a reboot
yeah where i played the grandpa of
castle absolutely yeah absolutely no i'm
in a reboot like five years from now
when they're like hey we want to do a
movie for a castle or we want to do i
think i would be
happier if i was farther away from that
because it's so close still it's so
close still i feel like i've done it
like crazy right but
point being
if
if this town needs me it'll be like in
short spurts i won't have to live here
i'll get a call and i'll say yeah i can
come in i'll fly in and
i'll maybe have a little place here i
don't i won't keep my my my house here i
would maybe rent that out or
do you think you're close to perhaps
moving away from los angeles because
that's sort of like what people are
doing nowadays especially with covet
happening i have a lot of friends my
friend chris has gone off to uh
atlanta my friend tom welling just moved
to northern california and like wayne
are listen there's a lot of things that
people can do to work remotely right now
i think we're all discovering that i'm
really interested in the folks that are
going off to these little islands in the
tropics that have good wi-fi and that's
their new life that's what you're
excited about they're living in a shack
on a beach somewhere instead of going to
an office in some you know
mid-eastern state
i think that's fantastic wow grow your
horizons man
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify
i don't know what i would do without
shopify when i first started um
with the inside of you online store my
podcast has a store
the inside of you online store uh i
didn't know what to do
i didn't know do you have to build
something do you have to build some kind
of website do you have to
shopify makes it so easy to sell your
products i started out with a t-shirt i
believe you guys remember or a mug
now i've got like 30 40 products it's
easy to navigate it's easy to know what
products doing really well what products
aren't doing as well
uh it tells you how many you know if you
have how many you have left your
quantity it does everything for you it
tells you what you're making at the end
of the month it tells you which products
are making the most money yada yada yada
i love shopify i couldn't do the podcast
without them they really helped me i've
had very little issues at all and if i
ever have an issue they respond to me so
quickly so look shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business so upstart
startups and establish businesses alike
and sell everywhere synchronize online
and in-person sales and effortlessly
stay informed
scaling your business is a journey of
endless possibility like inside of you
shopify powers millions of businesses
from first sale to full scale reach
customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
the detailed reporting of conversion
rates profit margins and beyond shopify
is more than a store folks connect with
your customers drive sales manage your
day-to-day shopify instantly lets you
accept all major payment methods so go
to shopify.com
inside all lower case for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside right now shopify.com
inside inside he was brought to you by
helix sleep uh i don't know what you're
sleeping on but if you're waking up and
you're feeling like crap
if you're just waking up and going gosh
i can't sleep
you sound like freaking napoleon
dynamite it's the worst sleep ever god
it's the worst man there's nothing worse
than a bad night's sleep but just your
whole day is ruined i can barely get
through the days as is i need to sleep
and what what do we do most of the most
of our lives ryan spend most of our
lives sleeping and you said ruined
ruined ruined can't you say ruined i
guess so yeah yeah i said ruined
but look
helix sleep is great because you know
you contact these guys and you take a
sleep quiz now this isn't a quiz that i
failed all quizzes
this is a quick quiz
designed to find out what you what's
best for you
and that quiz takes no time at all it
takes two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot and even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers i'm a medium
medium mattress sleeper
that's me not too soft not too hard
right down the old middle strike me as a
medium yeah because i've had back
problems and uh the helix mattress
really helps me out nice um i would
recommend that if uh you know for well
look everybody's different so you know
yeah take the quiz for crying out loud
uh it's been awesome getting message
messages from so many of you telling me
how helix really helps you guys and that
makes me feel good because i'm not the
only one that's that's feeling that it's
a lot of people uh if you're looking for
a mattress just take the quiz order the
mattress that you're matched to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again because who
wants to go to a damn mattress store
helix is awesome and you don't need to
take my word for it it was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired magazine and all
you have to do
is go to helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
inside take their two-minute sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
and they have a 10 year warranty and you
get to try it out for 100 nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
inside that's helix sleep.com inside for
up to 200 off and two free pillows
how often do you vacation
how often do you take a break in a year
well typically at christmas and during
hiatus so twice a year twice a year and
you would say you probably work 10
months a year on the rookie
ish yeah this this year for sure yes how
do you stay positive how do you stay i
positively love my job that actually is
easy that part
you love your job i really do you wake
up and you go
here we go yeah i don't know
not every job is as stress-free and
kind and we've built a community
well you i always say this because i've
heard this is like the lead actor sets
the sort of the mood of the show listen
i've been the lead actor on stressful
jobs i i haven't changed at all
sometimes it's just
there's a
cornucopia of things that can happen to
make it stressful sometimes it's
stressful beyond your control
right i wish it were up to me every time
was castle stressful
castle was stressful just if not just
for the schedule alone
it was an intense schedule five days a
week or six days a week but five and
sometimes six
and how did you cope with that uh not
well you can look at photos of me during
that time and just get kind of more
tired and bloated as years go on
well how did you get through it because
there's been moments where i i've seen
other actors or i've seen myself going
how am i gonna get through this yeah how
how do you i'm just so tired i'm just so
tired i don't even passes and then
eventually there's a light at the end of
the tunnel and then
you kind of aim at that and then
when it ends that's the thing it's
finite right it's not going to last
forever you can make it well what about
therapy do you go to therapy i've gone
to therapy
i don't feel any pressing problems that
are haunting me i'm a pretty happy guy
you are a pretty happy guy yeah you're
pretty chill who do you talk to when you
have things on your mind like who is my
brother all the time i got a couple of
buddies i'll talk to alan tudyk all
doctors
yeah we've been buddies for a long time
yeah since serenity uh before that fire
firefly and before that
he was my burrito waiter in new york
city but i was working on soap and he
was attending juilliard he was what the
favorite my favorite burrito place we
realized years later that he worked
there that he worked there while i was
attending he was actually my waiter on
more than one occasion
he told you that we realized together we
we kind of came to that and now you've
been friends for how long
oh only 20 years
20 years that's uh that's a long time
you're 51 now you don't look 51 keep
talking you don't look 51. keep talking
i'm going to be 50
in july yeah
do you feel i know you've only been
there a short time
but do you feel like the 50s are going
to be the best years of your life
because i hear different things 50s are
great 60s are great because the 40s
weren't great for me
sorry i'm not asking for sorry
i'm just i'm just wondering how the 50s
are so far for you and are you looking
forward to them yeah so far so good man
i might yeah i'm probably one of the
luckier people you'll ever meet
yeah i mean i'm
it's easy to look back at life and say
oh at that point in time i was in the
perfect position i can look back i
thought i had you know all these
problems i really didn't i was in the
perfect position i remember i was i was
on a sitcom for a little while two girls
and a guy that was the one and a pizza
place oh yeah yeah two guys and a girl
would be two places two guys a girl in a
pizza place right
and
i was in the perfect position i wish i
took advantage of it better than i did
what did you do
what i didn't do we the that incredible
schedule of the sitcoms i should have
been traveling every three weeks i
should have took them off to some crazy
wonderful location i didn't i didn't
take advantage of that incredible
schedule but now you're making up for
that
i don't have that kind of schedule
anymore but it's it's it's a kinder
schedule than something i'm used to we
have a fantastic cast right everybody
the whole conceit of that show i'm we're
talking about the rookie now we're done
everybody are we everybody back in the
rook now we're talking about the rookie
all right the whole conceit is that i'm
the old guy right so everybody there is
by nature of the story younger than me
there was a lot to potentially contend
with with a bunch of
younger actors but
we've got these
pros these people who just
come to work and they just know exactly
what they're doing
they find challenges in different ways
because
the job itself is not a challenge oh we
can make this work better if i switch
that would you like to say that line
instead that way it's not across the
room and you could just say to her and
that way people are solving problems all
the time they bring their a-game every
day
the show can rest heavily on the
shoulders of any one of them at any time
do you have a smaller not a smaller part
you're the leader yes you do yes i do so
you have scenes you're not in yeah a lot
of scenes that's it
this the story branches out into
different adventures so yes by nature
every scene i'm not in that's an
afternoon i'd not work
because castle was every scene every
scene every
of your life let's admit it
people you pay the devil in other words
people say so you're on a show you're
making money you're but you do sacrifice
i'm just letting everyone know that you
do sacrifice eight years of his life he
didn't have any time so those eight
years were gone yeah they were just
working now yeah again it's so it's it's
hard to complain because it's
complaining for you that's what you're
doing you are building a foundation for
sure sure and there is sacrifice but
yeah i had friends call me up and say
hey are we okay and like i need to hear
from you anymore
i don't have any time i don't have any
time all right so i see that you really
enjoy this you do this for
years to come
i could squeeze in a few more years of
this real easy yeah i could yes do you
want to direct
i don't have the eye
i don't know what do you mean you don't
have you i don't believe that you have
to understand oh well let's shoot this
like this that way it's a faster scene
or let's make sure we got a a shot of
this coming because to tell the story
and the the
the through line of the whole thing and
how speed and is important and bring
this forward yeah i don't have they
asked you sure they've said do you have
any interest and they kind of give you
the squinty weirdy look no i don't don't
worry about me it's too much work it's a
model you know i'm already working yeah
god bless you if you can do it yeah
fantastic and i've seen people do it
well do you direct uh i joined an
episode of smallville directed at a
feature film i directed a couple shorts
i'm gonna probably direct the horror
movie how were you received when you
directed uh i think people really
came to play came to bat they for me
they really worked hard for me they i'm
fun to be around um uh you know as well
i was working on a low budget i really
am for the most part a lot of fun to
work to be around but i i'll tell you
that's what's
debilitating when you're always trying
to appease everybody please everybody
you know and i shot a movie where i was
in my hometown so my everybody was
coming to see me and it was just and i
was the lead actor in the movie and i
would never do that again
but
i felt like i do have an eye i could do
this
um i you know i wish i had a little bit
of a better script i wish i had more
time there's certain things when you're
shooting 100 pages in 16 days or
something you know in the middle of
indiana worth no tax credit and you know
i'm not no excuses but i'm like if i
could do that
i could do anything i really feel that
way
but uh yeah i felt like i'm i'm pretty
good to work with i don't think people
would say god he was hard to work with i
don't think you'll ever hear that do you
think people would ever say that about
you
i don't i'm sure there were moments when
i was a little diva there were moments
[ __ ] i'm sure on smallville where i was
just upset about something and i was you
know i wouldn't take it out on anybody
but i was like oh my god what's wrong
with that guy
yeah i wonder i wonder what people say i
think in large by and large i think i'm
a good guy yeah but i'm sure people
would say he's a little tense today
you're a little tense
i've had days where i'm more quiet than
other days just maybe might retired or
sure or something like that but i don't
know i i just i don't try not to bring
stress to work right it's just a job or
just make-believe guys and you try to
work with people that you enjoy working
with i do try to do that's the good
thing about being a lead because you can
make those decisions we're like hey this
person brings us down let's get rid of
this guy oh is that what you do
no but yeah
yeah i have done that before not with an
actor but with uh crew guys
you know where it was just like hey
these guys are chauvinistic they're
telling horrible jokes on set in front
of people well there's uh
you know let's get them out of here
let's get them out let's bring the ship
down let's get these guys out uh stuff
like that or you know
it's hard i mean do you ever have guest
stars that come in and they just you
know they just can't do it they're too
nervous they're too stressed out they
you have to kind of babysit them or
i think a stressed out person you can
deal with pretty easy it's when someone
comes in and isn't very gracious or kind
that's when i you've had that
it's so rare it's so rare but yeah it
happens it's so rare right
but
do you step up as like the lead guy
saying you know
there's not much people will do in front
of me
really that's what i've learned that
mine it's always when you're not on set
my experience at work is different from
other people's experience at work i have
learned this much
what are you talking about this place is
great yeah for you
like
right yeah sometimes sometimes that can
be an issue so i think people are are
tend to be well behaved around me but
right
i tend to come to work and be prepared
yeah do an okay job and be relaxed and
if people are relaxed they do their best
work yeah
serenity and firefly if talking about
reboost would you would you you've been
asked a million times but would you do
that why wouldn't i do that it was one
of the best things that ever happened to
me now let me ask you because i've read
an article or something that says you
know this was the best acting job i've
ever had i think that was for firefly
i mean yesterday
yes at the time yeah
right yes
but my question is and you could just
divert if you want
what if they do these projects without
joss whedon
oh that would be heartbreak
because he created them yeah those are
those are his
how can you
how would you well because of all the
controversy and all the stuff that
happened
what's your take on that or would you
rather not speak
um i just wonder correct me listen i
i read that article yes um
nowhere in there at any point in time
did he mention
firefly
i
you know i
i had an entirely that was not my
experience with that man
what was your experience
funny
self-deprecating
incredibly talented
maybe a little haunted i mean right
listen by his own admission that guy's a
work in progress and i appreciate that
um
i would work with josh again in a second
i would work with him again in a second
and has he ever hinted about doing one
of these projects again
nathan
i mean how do you feel about uh we we
talk we joke we we fantasize if i s if i
say anything too solid it'll go crazy i
mean i hate being responsible for that
crap but
yeah but um
that's
an entire cast and crew of people who
had a fantastic job on that job
it was short-lived so it was
it didn't have an opportunity to suck
you know it just didn't were you
surprised how that didn't have legs that
it didn't although fans just to this day
eat it up the the fan base is remarkable
so it did have legs i was surprised
at how we were treated
i was surprised at how it ended i kept
saying guys don't worry
we're telling great stories people love
it's a good show we're doing everything
right don't worry and then you cancel
that's one hour later someone's
heartbreaking oh my gosh yes oh my god
it was terrible
and then
this whole
fan base i mean a huge fan base you go
to cons how many people what percentage
want to talk about serenity or firefly
you know i'll tell you i i couldn't uh i
mean
at this point you have so many projects
people really rarely go to just the one
so they'll list off a bunch but i'll to
that i'll say this i used to be able to
spot a firefly fan
i used to say oh
is it the shirt
is it the uniform typically a
generational thing uh yeah
you'd think you would know
and uh
that's now a thing of the past i no
longer have that gauge where i can say
oh that's a castle fan and that's a
firefly fan that's because it's just now
uh the castle fans have uh
everyone's gotten older first of all
everybody's gotten old along with me
right right so my kind of the
generational thing is gone um but i'll
i'll be surprised how many grandmas are
huge fans of firefly
really i'll pick them for a castle right
off the bat and they'll say oh that was
good but firefly
wow you know maybe they saw a castle and
they go i got to see everything else
this guy's in and then they go back and
they watch all this stuff isn't that
nice that we're in a
you know an
entertainment parrot
kind of a not a paradigm or just a
situation where
if you oh i like that actor i'm gonna
watch everything they've ever done and
press the button and off youtube and
they can do that
that's a beautiful thing right i have a
problem though i sound like a
grandfather i have i do have a problem
with the amount of shows that are on
television you have a problem because
you can never remember your netflix
password that's not entirely untrue
but seriously it's just like it used to
be where it's just like it was a
prestige there was a coolness there was
now it's like have you seen this no have
you seen that no
it's on this channel what what channel
is that
peacock peacock
there's millions of millions of
platforms and this is great this is
great for actors and it's great for i'm
not saying it's not great it's just like
oh my god what's good anymore pretty
soon they'll all consolidate into three
do you think and then those three will
be like back in the day nbc abc cbs
battle of the network stars remember
those yeah
that would be amazing yeah big softball
game would be amazing
do you um i think at this point in your
career
at 50 i mean you're young but i think
you you deserve a star on the on the
hollywood walk of fame
have you not had that yet no no i don't
have that i mean two successful huge
series network series i mean the world
knows you it's like at this point how do
you get a
a star on the hollywood walk of fame
that's a good question there's a there's
a process i'm sure that i've never
actually participated in yeah
i
but i i went to a ceremony once that was
for who
ryan reynolds got a star really well i
can understand that right
and you went there he invited you yeah i
got an invite are you guys still friends
good friends yeah we're buddies yes we
still talk yes we still talk he go see
his family
uh we i haven't seen him in an awfully
long time listen we're both
busy working on different coasts it's
right he's got a family like i mean
but it's one of those no love lost
relationships but you know i think i've
heard that walk the hollywood walk of
fame somebody has to pay the 25 000 for
the star somebody has to step up and say
i'm going to pay the 25 or the 50 000
and you can get a star
so
we could right now restart a google me
for michael rosenbaum's
star in the hollywood walk of fame
now do we get to pick where it goes does
it go right in front of mine would end
up man
mine would end up like on [ __ ] uh
you know down there los feliz ivar and
yeah further further it's like what is
this star out here what's all this stuff
on my stomach this is my rabbi
this rosenbomb guy what the hell is he
doing here i don't know i don't
understand it uh suicide squad yeah uh
the detachable kid tdk
uh james gunn recently said uh maybe i'm
misquoting but something like uh hey he
didn't die
is that true that's true uh critical
critical condition was my the last you
hear of my
uh
my character's plight why do you think
he said that
why do you think why do you think he
said that i think it's important to be
accurate when people are making
assumptions about he was ripped apart
what i saw the movie
that was his thing he did to cover this
that was his ability to be detached and
then reattached it comes right back
together i think he might have said that
because he wants to bring you back
somewhere listen no one's arguing with
that
how is it how how much do you love
working with james gone
you guys have a relationship i've had a
relationship a long time but you've had
a relationship probably longer
probably just like a maybe eight months
longer maybe eight months yeah i think
we're right about the same time um but
uh i met james auditioning for
slither that's right and as i was
leaving the room i said where are you
guys gonna film this and he said
vancouver i said oh i'm canadian
he said is that right
he wrote it down
here and i think he did i think that's
how i got the role because you know
hiring local cheaper it's a big deal
you'll live in vancouver while we're
shooting this we'll pay you a lot less
we'll pay you in canadian it's not about
how much you get paid i think it's about
the tax credit stuff oh tax credit stuff
yeah but you guys had a great working
relationship oh my god
he first of all he loves his job he and
he's really really good at he really
enjoys telling stories and just dreaming
up these crazy kooky things and then
making them happen sure and he sees it
all unfolding in front of him after all
this you know build up and creating and
putting it all together and then finally
the pieces come together and he's so
jazzed about it
and when this broke down and this won't
work and this guy can't do it and now
this isn't working right and it all
falls apart he doesn't fall apart he
just kind of laughs oh jesus okay all
right look here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna uh okay okay you've seen him
that happened where it's like holy [ __ ]
the days could be ruined everything
could be thrown away
and he steps up when he it's it's
watching someone uh you know do a job
that's easy is is great and watching how
much fun they have that's fantastic
watching someone deal with adversity i
think you see far more of their
character and integrity
and that's where i think uh one of the
many places
james excels that makes me think right
when you said that it makes me think
about myself
how i deal with adversity
um
i'm i'm pretty good
but
do you lose your temper
um
no
i sort of like there you know there was
there was one instance on on a set on
set that uh
we had to block shoot because it was
raining and we couldn't do things on
sticks and we had to so we had to shoot
in one direction for 10 pages
everything in that direction and then
turn around that's true and i was
completely lost completely lost like i i
couldn't i mean
it was hard for me to understand what
was happening it was just very
and my that's what first ads are for and
that's what your dp is for if you have
good ones and um
i remember going hey
um
bradley and
my first ad i said hey come here for a
second let's let's have a conversation
and i just looked at him and i go
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do they go
all right all right well it's this is
difficult you know they said it was you
know this is hard let's let's figure out
yeah because my mind doesn't work like
this i'm more linear this is this is
hard to fathom to shoot everything in
this direction and remember exactly he's
like all right well let us help you
and that was a very s
i felt like that was a good decision as
opposed to just going all right here's
what we're going to do and because i
think i would have failed i needed help
at this moment it only happened one day
but i felt
it did make me feel like a failure even
though
i know it was so hard on myself it
sounds like you did everything right i
know but i remember i was like you can't
do this by yourself you're a grown
[ __ ] man you can't [ __ ] handle
this that's the who's talk whose voice
is that is that this is the inner child
your child talks like that no no no i
don't have a child but it's like the the
interlude i mean you're the energy can't
do the inner child you can't that's how
he talks to you he's something send that
kid to his room yeah you go to your
[ __ ] room kid relax yeah yeah are you
not do you ever get like that where you
have to ask for help or you're just like
you do thank god i i rely heavily on the
people around me come on
you do they're all it seems like you
always have your [ __ ] together like you
always know what to do listen you can
micromanage and you can try to do
everybody's job but they're amazing at
their job they bring years and years of
experience
rely on them trust them all right dress
them hey will this work for you will we
ever get married no you knew you and me
yet no yeah not us but do you think is
it something like you know you ask
people you're like you're gonna get
married somebody like why why get
married what is what is unless you're
gonna have children why why do i need to
get married i have a very rich
single life i think you do too sure
you're not sitting here lonely in your
house you know despondent or anything
sometimes
oh sorry man sometimes sometimes i get
lonely and i think god i wish i had
someone to share this thing all the time
yeah you know because here's what
happens here's how i think my friends
are all married or they have
relationships most of them and when i'm
like hey let's go to the beach like uh
it's tuesday at noon dude we're working
and i'm like
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] your work
no we can't we're not we can't do it so
i'm like god i need someone with me that
i can go on these adventures and do
these things what if they're working too
that's true that's a problem there you
go you just solved it
but go ahead you're going to say
something i was going to say if in 10
years time the two of us aren't married
let's promise each other
to hunt each other for sport
to hunt each other for sport
is that did you just agree i i was
hoping you'd say let's let's just get
married let's look together let's say
i'll be your buddy i didn't be your
gilligan i didn't mean to
the signals
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
oh man all right look this is called
[ __ ] talking with nathan fillion how
dare you we did my mom watches this does
she will she watch this
she will does your mom watch everything
you've done uh yeah i think she tries
yeah every episode of casual oh yeah
yeah yeah
how many episodes of castle did you do
let me guess
i'm gonna guess you did
190
that sounds close
i don't know you don't you don't know
how many episodes you did they didn't
have 150th episode party maybe maybe
it was a cake once
how many rookie episodes
i don't know that either you don't
remember the cakes
this is made me laugh this is good this
is good uh this is called [ __ ] talking
with nathan philly and these are my love
lovable patrons who who keep the podcast
afloat you're amazing i love you if you
want to join patreon i'll message you
back uh patreon.com inside of you
nathan's trying to reach the camera it's
way up there is he lifting his head
there's his head there it is
uh this is from claudine how much fun
was it playing ahead in santa clarita
diet
okay um so
i i did the first season of santa
clarita diet i did a couple episodes
there had a wonderful time i was really
dying to work with uh tim lafont and
drew barrymore it was something i
really really wanted to do wow and uh i
was able to do it and had had a
wonderful time were they kind oh my gosh
was timothy kind like you can't even
believe really better than you'd hope
was one of those guys
wow and drew so sweet
so sweet how long did you work on the
show
oh a couple episodes two maybe two three
and you had a blast had a great time had
a great day had a great day i like it um
i like hearing that coming back they had
pre-filmed all the scenes with a little
dummy head
and then i got all this makeup done to
look like a a
bodyless head and then
sat in a
structure that held my head in place oh
phobia you had a couple cameras on me
and they ran the scenes and i did my
lines against the pre-filmed
scenes
so it was just me in this weird chair
with my head restricted
and you can't even move your head
i realize as an actor i
i move my head
i move my head quite a bit it's a bit of
a crutch were you claustrophobic at all
not claustrophobic no you're not closed
in it's just that you you can't move
you're just kind of limited to what you
can potentially were you sitting there
going do i look stupid does this look
right it just sucked a bit of the
process and the fun out of it it was
that's all that's all it was just wasn't
was it great as as a product yes i think
it worked out really great and i'm glad
they included me but uh it was
not nearly as fun as the first season
drew seems like someone who would mess
up a lot of their lines and just have
fun with it and just laugh a lot
huh no she seemed to be
more
prepared in trying nuances and she she
was really into her character and she
would try little fine little
pieces and wonderful little melodies and
yeah she she she's harder working than
she is forgetful is she easy to have a
crush on you can understand why people
have crushes on her oh my god yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's instantly like oh
my god
crushable yeah but because she's so kind
too she's kind to everybody she knows
everybody's names that's so important i
have a feeling you know everybody's name
too that's one of the things you really
really try to do yeah i'm trying to do i
always hate the new guy too
do you too yeah the new camera operator
whoever it is they go hey i'm daley
david nice to meet you what do you do
for us oh i'm going to be the new
such and such oh great welcome i'm
really glad you're here i think you're
gonna have a good time hey everybody new
guy look me right in the eyes and
everybody goes oh what are you doing
yeah we're gonna need new dave
oh that's great yeah that's great
trivia question what's your camera
operator's name on the rookie uh we have
a number of them uh one of my favorites
is uh cody cody see right there pulled
it out of his head most actors couldn't
do that ryan i've worked with many
actors who are on set with for years
with the same crew guys who couldn't
tell you their effort names now here's
another one i
while we're at work if i see someone on
a coffee break over there and they've
got their mask pulled down and they're
having a coffee and a muffin and they're
eating something i have no clue
who they are
when they put their mask back on i go oh
it's ted there you go
ted from accounting that's where we are
now i i have been working with some
people now for two years i've never seen
their face
aside from there that's sad
sad and kind of weird when you finally
see their mouth and it's kind of crazy
that you recognize them with the mask on
that's all you've got
you don't recognize them with the mask
off it's hard to place like who's that
sophie if you had to lip-sync a song to
save your life what would it be
lip sync a song to save my life would it
be 80s when i narrowed down to the 80s
sure yeah yeah
i would do certainly something from the
80s uh
let's do take on me so needless to say
i'm odds and ends but that's me i'm
stumbling away that's a good one i like
it
um i hope i would have time to prepare
before uh mike
r says are you going to michael
rosenbaum's uh 50th birthday party in
july
i'm asking you that was me oh you want
to come yeah will you be here july it's
on a sunday sunday night
i have a wedding in july if it's on if
it's on a you know i hope it's not it's
gonna be fun and we get the spasmatics
to play you came to my last birthday i
don't think you can call him that
can you not
can you not say spazz anymore
jesus where are we
dj kento
oh this is this we already answered this
buddy sorry about this but you know the
detachable kid made it made it out a lot
by the end of the movie any chance we'll
see tdk on the next season of peacemaker
if
james knows what's good for him yeah
i knew that lulu s will there ever be
another con man
episode season
oh boy con man something that alan and i
put together crowd funded it
yeah we did we that was a that was alan
actually allen was that a lot of work pj
it was for them yes for them
i had a kind of a backseat kind of role
that was kind of an idea man how would
you do it like this sounds good okay
great talk to you later i gotta go back
to work right you didn't have time to do
all the you know the the the [ __ ] really
did the
the lion share but would you do another
season if they came back and said hey we
got another season sure that'd be fun
yeah sure you would yeah it's crazy look
at you going to work and working with
your buddies and doing fun stuff with
your friends that's how i imagined this
industry that's what i kind of it's the
best dreams it's the best it would be
like we'd all be buddies and having fun
and doing that's what i always wish for
i always wish i always want to bring my
friends into it
i just heard a story an actor was
talking to me saying i asked to be let
go from a show
i thought what and it was just because
it was toxic it was a terrible place to
be they'd rather be
unemployed yeah then working
fruit plate
that is that that's incredibly
incredibly sad where would you rather be
yeah if it's that toxic you know and
you're going to work every day in a time
i mean imagine people who go to a to
five every day and it's toxic it's like
you know and they don't yeah it's not
just the entertainment industry yeah
it's just a brutal thing to have to deal
with you know you want to go to work and
at least have be surrounded by people
who
uh don't want to be there as well
you know or as you know i don't know get
along uh mary b which sitcom world past
or present would you like to live in
interesting sitcom world past would it
be seinfeld would you like to live in
that world
well it was so
angst uh driven in seinfeld i i think i
would like to live in the uh the friends
new york
friends new york yeah well you ryan i
was thinking friends as well yeah um
actually no i would i like to live in
pawnee indiana with parks and rec
really yeah a little i think the small
town of it would try but uh i mean just
but everyone's good to each other and
everyone's nice and like you feel like
things good things can happen to people
ah i'm gonna go with gilligan's island
yeah huh
was that is that considered a sitcom i
think it was a sitcom i'm on an island
with two hot women and a couple of cool
dudes you know and an old couple used to
run home at 3 30 as fast as my little
legs could carry me through the canadian
winters to get home by four which is
when gilligan's album come on because i
wanted to see
a tropical
location do you can you sing the song or
at least do you know the words to the
song yes all of them yes can you name
the characters yes
let's see if we can do it together
five passengers that sailed the day for
three hours for a tour a three hour tour
the weather started getting rough the
tiny ship was tossed if not for the
courage of the fearless who were will it
i mean it would be good it would be lost
senator nelson island with gilligan the
skipper too
the billionaire his wife
the movie star the professor and mary
here on gilligan's island do you know
for the first time in the beginning when
that show is on they say the professor
end all the rest you've only got you've
got the one left
the professor and all the rest yeah that
was a big screw you didn't
mary was forgotten and they put her in
there and it rhymed even
um leanne there have been rumors about
it we talked about this been rumors
about a firefly reboot floating around
the internet have you heard about these
rumors i've heard about the rumors yes
they are rumors
this is a really nice thing to say
nathan
this is from steph a stephae stephanie
mike huh or stephae vancouver okay hey
oh bad not good
just wanted to say you are a huge
inspiration to me oh i started writing
movies reviews and articles with the
pseudonym nathan jasper in honor of you
who got me interested in writing after
castle i don't have a question for you
but i did just want to say
thank you
wow that's sweet yeah that's really nice
you know that's
when i got started acting i found it
really uh thrilling to be up on stage
and everything was very immediate if you
did something great you knew it right
away and at the end everybody would clap
and you knew how they felt instant
gratification but when you
are doing tv and film there's nobody
there there's no no clapping no clapping
so
you don't get that part of it anymore
there's different challenges and i find
them fun and
fulfilling
but the applause i get now are those
responses worded
gratitudes those those those thank yous
those they mean a lot yeah they really
do my favorites are you know you
inspired me to do something or
another favorite is uh i watch it with
my daughter i watched it with my mom it
was the one time we could always count
on this or it was i was able to connect
and
just the thing the times where it brings
families and people together how often
do you get stopped on the streets well
i'm never in the streets anymore first
of all
but
i went to a party
uh not too long ago one of my first
parties back and uh met some nice people
they were very kind and then later on in
the evenings one of them came back and
sat down with me and just said listen i
didn't want to say anything in the
beginning but and they told me it was
like it's really hard to connect with a
teenage daughter it can be tough there's
a you know they're looking at their old
man in a certain way but the one thing
we could always do is we could get
together with castle i could always
count on that would be the time that we
could spend together and talk things and
talk about stuff and he would raise
issues we could have knee conversations
but he said it was meaningful to him
that's awesome made me feel great yeah
instead she went off to college and now
she came back and she said we have a new
series to watch who knows and he
introduced her she introduced him to
firefly oh i love that that's a nice
step i love you i love that i saw
serenity but i haven't seen firefly no i
think you're in retreat it's a lot of
people you'll already know
tutek sure uh marina yes backroom yes uh
uh jules dual state state who's
amazing um we're all still buddies still
is that true yeah yes this is a fire how
often do you get a text in a year from
these people maybe once or twice oh no
no no there's a text thread and we were
all just on it two days ago laughing
about something really yes who is your
favorite can you name a favorite who was
it that you just hit it off with and bef
except for allen because obviously the
20-year relationship
uh
boy
i really miss ron
i really miss ron
he and jewell really connected in an
incredible way it was wonderful to watch
that
um
all the ladies on that show were
incredibly
talented
and adept i think
by that point jewell had been on tv more
than the rest of us put together wow she
was just so
good at her job
she's just been doing it for so long
yeah and just you know adam and baldwin
legendary
legendary roles that guy he's fun to be
around he's a fun guy he's a good energy
he has the energy of a
child but the professionalism of an
adult he does
and calls you out on [ __ ] just like you
know gina has this very
regal
calm about her and then these amazing
little side
she's so good she's so good
everybody is just damn
good and kind it was such a great time
yeah such a great time yeah that was the
one that pulled me out of the mud that
was the one where nobody would look at
me to play a lead role
nobody in this town i couldn't get hired
anything less than uh that's all i see
you as a leading guy i don't see you as
a character guy i mean that's funny
because i kind of do see you still as a
character guy too because you see a
suicide squad and things like that i was
he always the other guy or the boyfriend
of the friend or i've rarely been the
guy rarely almost never i've always been
either bald guy or you were the villain
i was the villain of the story were you
not i was
that's a big thing i know it was a good
deal i'm i'm grateful very grateful what
this is it what what is what's next are
you just kind of taking your time doing
the rookie doing your show is there
anything else that you kind of is kind
of brewing in the background things that
you might partake in
i'm trying to build that machine that uh
makes money without going out and acting
for it i want to try to produce some
things so we got a couple of things on
the burner to try to get going
to uh
to build you know from the ground up
some animation stuff some drama stuff or
a streaming service how do you feel
about the nft [ __ ]
i wish
i wish i understood that stuff it's so
hard i've had people talk to me about it
and i'm like oh i read articles i don't
get it i read articles i don't get it i
i i get it i get what's happening yeah i
don't get why someone would buy it
that's the key yeah you're gonna have
this but you can't put it in your house
it's just on your phone or it's it's
just not tangible but if everybody has
it there's only one of a kind i'm like
yeah but i'm like look i have this as a
it's like you walking to my house going
where are all your movie posters they're
on my phone
but
there's something cool about it and
there there's different things that
people are is it gonna be a thing is it
gonna take off
is it taking off
people are making money on it so it's
got attention the more attention it gets
and the more people make money off it
the more people want to get involved
yeah it kind of starts to feed itself
isn't that how bitcoin was yes and i can
understand it sort of like if you want
to raise money for a movie and they have
cool things that they can get by you
know investing in a movie you you could
become uh you know you get the the
script before it comes out you get uh
you know certain things
maybe that you're a part of this
filmmaking process like i was thinking
maybe something like that but i don't
know it's it's it's it's it's hard to
fathom it's still hard to grasp but hey
good for people yeah right yeah yeah
this has been a tree
are we done i think so i'm out of here
this has been a really great time thanks
for having me i just like chatting with
you listen your voice
is my asmr
really
you're asleep you're asleep right now uh
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you once again this has been a damn
treat uh let's go and see the electric
truck why are you gonna lock eyes with
me when you say it like that because i
really like you
let's go take a look at your riviera
let's do it
good interview i enjoyed it i enjoyed it
i enjoyed going on he has a scooter it's
like a two-person scooter
that i can't explain it i don't know
what it's called it's this weird
[ __ ] super scooter that's almost like
a motorcycle and a car in one yeah and
we rode on it around my neighborhood
after the interview and i had a great
time and he always is he loves his
gadgets he loves his toys just like i do
but yeah that yeah that was a that was
fun yeah it was it was fun uh thank you
and again if you enjoyed nathan's
filling nathan's fillion that should be
a movie
now it's time for nathan's fillion
nathan's follies
anyway
whatever
whatever i'm not firing on all cylinders
right now i'm not either
like excuse me if i'm not full of fun
here
but uh thank you for listening today
thank you for supporting the podcast if
you want to join patreon to support the
podcast in other ways it really helps
patreon.com inside of you thank you
cumulus thank you westwood one
i think they're one i just call them
like say both their names thank you
bryce my producer thanks ryan my
engineer thanks jason my editor i love
you guys couldn't do it without you and
uh we're gonna keep these episodes
coming i'm gonna keep bugging guests to
be on my show that's what i do i call
them i email them i email friends of
mine like seth green
seth how can we get will wheaton i'll
email him for you and then finally i
hope we get will wheaton
so that's how i do it i bug my friends
until i have no friends anymore and i do
it all for you
i do it all for
you new vultures yeah patriot.com inside
you go to the inside of you online store
to get cool merch tons of cool new merch
go to the sunspin.com to get uh zooms
and other band stuff the new album is
coming out in the next couple months i
hope you purchase it and i hope you
listen to it it'll be available on all
streaming services uh
that's really all i have to say um if
you want to listen to anything else you
could follow us at the inside inside you
podcast on the
instagram and facebook and insideipod on
the twitter uh let's go to the what
i was agreeing you were agreeing well
right now we're gonna do the uh
these are the top tiers this is part of
the package if you join patreon and
you're a top tier patron you get your
name shouted out on the podcast how cool
is that ryan that's awesome
it's incredible here we go
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e bryant h nico p robert b
jason w raj she joshua d cjp jennifer n
stacy l jamal f janelle b kimberly
e correct mike e eldon soprano 99 more
san diego m chad w leanne p janine r
maya p matty s belinda n chris h dave h
g brad d ray h tab of the t tom
n correct liliana a talia m betsy
uh d correct chad l rochelle marion meg
k dan and big stevie w angel am rihannon
c cory k super sam dev next and michelle
a jeremy c andy t cody r
gav
nato gavinator david c john b brandy d
yvore camille s the c joey m willie f
david h design otg eugene and leah
chris p
nicky g
corey nicole heather l jake b james b
getting to the nitty-gritty here bob at
megan t
mel s orlando c john b caroline r
rob e paul c christine s sarah s
eric h spring spring jennifer r shane r
emma r
mark m germaine no jeremy v
jeremy v
andrew
has spoken
andrew m robert g
zatucci 77 zatuichi
zatoichi and andreas
and
uh
couldn't do it without you guys i really
appreciate you and don't forget
talkville is coming out july 13th the
new smallville rewatch podcast with me
and tom willing as a host ryan tayz will
be on it
he'll be there he'll be watching
episodes and talking about him freely
with us it's nice because ryan has never
seen episodes and so when he sees him
for the first time he really tells us
how he feels and i also tell you how i
feel because a lot of episodes i didn't
see nor do i remember but when i watch
them it every all the memories come back
they flood i'm flooded with these
memories there's so many memories so
many memories
memories
uh thank you guys for listening i
appreciate it i love you uh from michael
rosenbomb here in the hollywood hills of
california and ryan tez who's also here
in hollywood california he is that's
correct little wave at the camera
remember be good to yourselves guys um
we've you are all you have really
we are all we have
does that make sense
yeah man i mean if you don't take care
of yourself i mean
who you can't take care of other people
you can't you can't if you take care of
other people you're not taking care of
yourself you're just you're you're in
for bruising that's that's what i've
learned you're in for hell
you know not giving yourself time not
giving yourself love yeah i've been
there guys and i'm telling you it ain't
sweet it ain't a good road to go down
all right it's enough [ __ ] i'll talk
to you later although i'm serious be
good to yourselves see ya
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast